are you Peter everything's going good
rich you know I just have one very quick
comment about your thing about draft
tricks and you know and and sort of
saying who was picked you know what I
noticed last year okay well last April
so I was with the 49ers uh and I was
there you know with them sort of
embedded with them on both of the first
two nights okay and so as the picks got
going in the first round and you know
inside a draft room they know the picks
or whatever two three four minutes
before Roger Goodell was doing it but it
would announce him and and at one point
when a couple of picks happen very
quickly right in a row uh it was like
seven or eight minutes elapsed between
it and so I'm honestly a little bit
surprised that there isn't more of sort
of the leaking of that and I know in the
NF in the in the NBA just from what I've
read about it that because they're
competing entities that they're
certainly not going to make a deal with
the NBA to to not you know Telegraph the
picks and so and plus I'm not really
sure that that it does things that it
that it does such deleterious that have
such deleterious effects to the telecast
of the show anyway well just my thought
well I mean let me give you let's let's
have a conversation on this before we
get to dairy tower because trust me I am
very well aware of how those pics are
getting backed up like plane sitting on
a runway at LAX yeah I am getting antsy
I want as soon as that pick is in I
wanted announced and I want it out there
right because I understand that I'm
getting scooped on on Twitter there's no
question about answer that that it's
getting out there and that if somebody
does have a second window open watching
the first window which is I'm hoping
consider the NFL Network coverage of it
that anybody who's watching thinks that
I'm is up-to-date as they are and thus
play-acting to try and create drama
whereas Mayock and I are sitting on that
set now with DJ and and Charles Davis
we are thoroughly in the dark and we are
kept that way because we want to be
surprised just like everybody else in on
Braille until that is no longer the
preferred method of draft information
delivery I don't think there's going to
be any change and I think the league is
going to try and keep a clamp down
certainly in the first round of tweeting
with their partners I think that well
it's going to you know last year the
league got very upset with Albert Breer
doing it on our site and doing it
through his Twitter account and I
understood that now when I was in there
I basically I mean I'm the one who
offered disagreement but I didn't I was
not looking very much at all other than
during breaks you know on Twitter or or
anything I was just in the moment in
there I mean you look at my timeline I
don't think that I don't know that I
said anything the entire first night is
a graph you know until it was over but
but be that as it may be that as it may
I think my point is that when you when
you have such a gap between the time the
actual pick was made and the time the
actual picks are announced by Roger
Goodell in my opinion I don't want to
say you're asking for trouble no you are
Ryu know you can basically you're
encouraging people who are competitive
people competitive reporters to just say
oh okay we won't say anything about this
well I'm not I'm not an employee of the
NFL you know and I understand and I do
understand that if we're talking about
20 seconds I get it but if we're talking
about five six seven minutes I don't I'm
not a big fan of holding on to
information that you know for that long
Peter and and I'm absolutely with you on
that in terms of asking for it the
league definitely wants to have for the
NFL Draft
a little bit of a show within the arena
as well as a
nod to the past sometimes the
commissioners you know will come out
with a veteran player a retiree or with
an actual United States veteran somebody
who's out there
fantastic I know I know but sometimes to
be out be very but the veterans either
and could literally be in the John when
it's time to get out there or ESPN's on
break and NFL Network isn't and they're
waiting for ESPN to come back from break
those are just not to get terribly deep
in the weeds but that yeah that's I
don't know what the solve is on all that
and also just to put the button on the
conversation you could have stopped your
sentence with the league was upset with
Albert Brewer and just put the period
there you didn't have to finish that
well look uh you know I understand that
there are some people in the legal over
the years of every problems an elder I
know that we move out I know that he's
all I know that as an editor-in-chief
which now I am I'm extremely happy that
he works for us as well I'll just tell
you that as well you should
okay what do you make of Derek what do
you make Peter King of the mmq be
joining me here on the Richard show what
do you make of the Derek Carr signing
and the well effect I mean good work all
I can say is good for Derek Carr because
what happens in the case of football you
know football salaries essentially uh is
that once Andrew Luck signs for twenty
four point six million a year the next
make a quarterback whoever it is is not
going to sign for less and that's all
there is to it and so now Derek Carr
gets to be the first twenty five million
dollar player average contract in NFL
history and good for him he's very
deserving he's a young guy who means
everything to that franchise and it's
somebody who's gotten to know them a
little bit I can just tell you that this
guy is a perfect not only representative
of the Raiders but perfect
representative of the NFL and if you saw
what NFL Films did on him during the
Indianapolis game I think your Christmas
Eve New Year's Eve whenever was when he
got hurt last
here how awesome a leader he is on the
field he's unbelievable so good for him
but I'll just say this like my first
thought when I looked at this contract
was well you know it's it's great you
know he beat everybody but in essence he
goes 25 million a year luck is 24-6
Brees is twenty four three carson
palmer's 24 four in Kirk Cousins is 23
nine so it's not like he wiped the floor
with everybody's butt but I am going to
say this that the reason why I think
that he just barely beat these guys
because he's different from Matthew
Stafford and Kirk Cousins because he's
starting at such a low level and that's
why I think his age did a really good
job plus the fact that in the last three
years of his contract Adam Schefter very
wisely reported this this morning that
in the last three years it will be his
contract will be paid by a corporation
in the state of Nevada and so and it
could be the last four years depending
on what year this franchise actually
moves to Las Vegas but at least in the
last three years you know whatever the
number is he'll save three four five
million dollars on the contract by not
having to pay any state taxes versus the
ownerís
and look I'm not a we all as Americans
especially very wealthy Americans should
pay our share of tax don't get me wrong
but I'm saying is a huge advantage and
part of what people should think about
when they think of this deal that the
tax ramifications are so good for him in
the last three years so then who's the
quarterback that heard about this deal
who's coming up in short order that is
high-fiving with their agents right now
well you know probably Matthew Stafford
but look you know I maintain this I have
written this if I had to bet 2018 team
for Kirk Cousins
it would not be Washington because
as although they could franchise them
one more year at 34 whatever and they
and probably they should okay I know
there are those in that organization who
say oh you know Jay Gruden's brilliant
will win with somebody else will place
the you know called McCoy or you know or
pick somebody else up whoever okay and I
look I'm not saying that Kirk Cousins
Johnny Unitas I'm saying he's pretty
darn good and I think that if he plays
in 2018 it will be for the franchise day
because just my opinions nothing that he
told me believe me and I know him a
little bit I traveled to England with
him on a trip where he was going to
spread the gospel of NFL football in
April but I just think that that you
know there's a little water under the
bridge there with how the team judged
him and sort of treated him over the
last year or so in terms of the
negotiations for a new contract so I
think that Kirk Cousins need a place
with a franchise number next year in
Washington or plays on a long-term deal
is a huge free agent somewhere else well
where does this all wind up Peter and by
that I mean this is that we're soon
going to have half the starters in the
NFL
one day maybe that days not next year
perhaps the year after we're gonna have
half the starters in the NFL making on
average over twenty million dollars a
year and on average about ten percent of
them will have a providing quarterback
correct half the starting quarterbacks
in the NFL will be making over twenty
million dollars a year and on probably
just spitballin here five to ten percent
of that group will have a Superbowl ring
on their resume that works but I mean I
mean here's the way I look you're paying
gunslingers basically who will mass who
amassed you know fantasy football
numbers but when it all comes down to it
playoff wins are not on the resume for a
lot of these I I would I would agree but
the fact is the fact is now that you
know an above average starting
quarterback in the NFL is a twenty
million dollar player period you might
like it you might not like it but I
think that what also contributed to
is said nobody talks about it okay I
mean look my jaw doesn't drop at Derek
Carr making 25 million it just doesn't
that is what a great player in the NFL
should make and I think this year he
will commend himself as one of the great
quarterbacks one of the top ten
consistent really good quarterbacks but
I think what nobody is talking about and
should talk about is Mike Glennon making
whatever he made 15 million so in other
words we're paying guys who we really
don't know about it over a short term
say two years we're paying them 15
million dollars when we have absolutely
no idea and they haven't done it but
we're just paying them because we want
to get it I get so many people poo pooed
the Mike Glennon contract and look I
like Ryan pace but I happen to think he
was competing against air and uh and and
I just do I you know I just think I
think Mike Glennon if you want to sign
Mike Glennon for eight million a year
and give him a ridiculous incentive
package great but I don't know why and I
don't know how you pay absolutely
unproven quarterbacks 15 million years
guys do not get that and will never get
it well last one for you then Peter is
because I am NOT against and I'm sure
you would say the same thing that gets
against those getting theirs I mean if
that's what the market bears it's what
the market bears and if that's what it
can be afforded it can be afforded it's
not our money but out of whose pocket is
it coming out of whose expense on a
roster does it come with a salary cap
being chewed up by so much of a one
player and many of whom were not well
you know what you have to realize though
if the salary cap went up this year
seven percent which I think it did and
last year went up I think eight percent
okay salary cap is continuing to rise
and so you have to speak about 25
million in relative terms I would bet
that the best quarterbacks in football
15 years ago made no bigger percentage
of the salary cap I'd love to look that
up in fact that the quarterbacks 15
years ago made no different or bigger
percentage or less of a percentage on
average
the salary cap then the guys are signing
for now so really what does it matter
yeah I just I don't think it's a big
deal and I don't think that because
Derek Carr who you always knew if you
have a great quarterback whatever the
number is 23 25 27 whatever it is
whatever that number is you're gonna pay
a really good quarterback in this league
you always have you always will the only
one who's been significantly below
market value in general has been Tom
Brady because he's always had this deal
with the Patriots and I'm this is
unofficial is an oddity but he's always
basically had this deal where hey look
if you pay the rest of the team if you
as long as you spend it a cap and pay
you know the rest of the players the
money that I could hold you up you know
do a stick up with I'm fine with that
and so even though he's made great money
he definitely I mean Peyton Manning got
every last dollar mostly when he played
I mean Brady just hasn't been that way
Peter thanks for the chat enjoy the Big
Papi retirement ceremony tomorrow night
I'm sure you will
hey thanks a lot H have a great wait you
got it that's Peter King me make you
EECOM joining us here on the Richard
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you liked
that video be sure to download our apps
don't have any memory on your phone
let's start to delete some of those
slow-mo videos you have and you know
which ones I'm talking about